[Aplausos]
cuando las negociaciones se acercan a su
fecha final para entregar un texto hoy
una de las salas plenarias donde hace
unos días Estaban reuniendo los líderes
políticos se llena de las voces de los
pueblos y de la sociedad civil que
exigen que sus demandas sean incluidas
en esta declaración de sanke al inicio
fue muy claro el enfoque de Justicia
pero a lo largo de las cosas esto se ha
venido diluyendo cada vez más y ahora
Necesitamos recuperar la perspectiva de
Justicia necesitamos que se reconozca la
deuda climática que existe del Norte al
sur y que esto puede incorporarse en
decisiones claves Como por ejemplo el
fondo de reparaciones de las de los
desastres climáticas que vienen
ocurriendo alrededor del mundo
[Aplausos]
solidaridad y la descolonización de la
sociedad y de la economía es lo que
piden en la declaración de los pueblos
que están leyendo ahora a mis espaldas
en este plantón en el que ha finalizado
la marcha que ha habido desde la
plenaria hasta esta zona de la cop27
hacemos un Wok out de la sala de
conferencias como el símbolo de protesta
de que nuestras voces no son escuchadas
y las sentada final está en un símbolo
de un bloque de un bloqueo corporal de
las propias negociaciones bueno nosotros
venimos acá para reivindicar los
derechos de la madre tierra que ha sido
sacrificado
por el modelo económico salvaje que se
ha implementado entonces venimos acá
para reclamar nuestros derechos verdad
para que existan
reparaciones a los daños y al sacrificio
de la madre tierra y por supuesto las
consecuencias en la vida de nuestros
pueblos habrá que esperar unas horas O
quizás unos días para saber si estás
demandas finalmente son incluidas en el
texto final que salga de la Cumbre
climática con 27